BUZZ FEED SAYS RIGHT PEOPLE ARE
RUINING AMERICA.
THE OSCARS, MAC AND CHEESE,
SNEAKERS, KOREAN POP MUSIC AND
PROTESTS.
JOE WRITES FOR THE HILL AND IS
ALSO WHITE.
YOU ARE NOT LISTED IN 37.
WHERE DO THEY GET OFF ON A LIST
LIKE THIS?
>> I THINK I'M ONLY HALF WHITE.
>> AT LEAST 16 THINGS YOU ARE
RESPONSIBLE FOR, TEN.
WHAT ARE THEY GETTING AT?
>> THEY ARE GETTING AT WHITE
PEOPLE ARE BAD FOR THE COUNTRY.
WHITE PEOPLE VOTED FOR PRESIDENT
LET'S PLAY A GAME.
SWAP OUT WHITE PEOPLE ROOPING RI
SWAP OUT WHITE PEOPLE ROOPING RG
AMERICA, YOU TELL ME HOW BUZZ
FEED THE EDITOR WOULDN'T BE
FIRED AND EVERY ADVERTISER
WOULDN'T BE BOYCOTTED.
BELIEVE ME, AFTER WE SAW THE
BACKLASH OF THE WRITERS OF
VANITY FAIR CAME FORWARD AND HAD
THINGS TO SAY ABOUT HILARY
CLINTON'S TERRIBLE BEHAVIOR,
THEY APOLOGIZED.
WILL THEY FACE BACKLASH OVER
THEY HAVE DONE THINGS BEFORE.
WHITE PEOPLE STATE COLONIZING
AND WHITE PEOPLE A PLAGUE TO THE
PLANET.
THIS APPEARS TO BE A THEME AT
ME OUT HERE.
BECAUSE OF THE STORY, I'M NOT
GOING TO WRITE IT ANYMORE.
>> DO YOU THINK THERE IS A
CHANCE THAT THEY ARE HAVING FUN,
THROWING IT OUT THERE TO GET US
TALKING ABOUT IT?
DO YOU THINK THERE'S AN AGENDA?
>> I THINK THEY ARE DESPERATE.
THEY MISSED THE REVENUE TARGET
50 TO $70 MILLION.
THEY WERE SUPPOSED TO HAVE AN